so let's talk about what you should
do at the first sign of dementia
now what are the first signs of dimension number
one loss of navigation spatial memory now what is
that that has to do with locating yourself in time
and space so let's say for example you're trying
to figure out where did i park my car are you
having problems with direction when you're driving
somewhere and you're completely and utterly
dependent on the gps all right number two is um
it's taking you longer to find the right words
number three you're more easily confused now
of course there's a lot of things in life that
we're confused about but if you just to compare
your past to the present is there some type of
drop in clarity i mean that could be one thing
number four you're repeating yourself now
there's many other symptoms of dementia but
these are the early signs dementia in alzheimer's
is a situation where your neurons cannot get
fuel anymore specifically glucose because
there's either resistance of fuel going
through the blood-brain barrier or the
neurons in the brain itself cannot get
fuel anymore so there's a problem with
these synapses connecting if the blood
has glucose and ketones together which is a
different source of fuel the brain will prefer
and take as priority the ketones over glucose
so in other words the preferred fuel of the
brain is ketones which is the byproduct of fat
burning and very rarely does an average person
run their body on ketones they're running
their body on glucose and then what happens
they start having insulin resistance and all
sorts of issues so now that doesn't work anymore
and so the most important thing you need to
know is you need to start feeding the brain
ketones okay ketones will bypass this damaged
mechanism of the glucose being absorbed and feed
the neurons directly so you're going to notice
a nice change in these symptoms for the better
so how do you increase ketones three ways you
lower your carbs get on a healthy keto eating plan
you start doing fasting i have a link down below
of how to do intermittent fasting going on low
carbs will increase ketones a certain amount but
when you're doing fasting you greatly elevate the
amount of ketones that the brain can use now the
other thing you can do is a transition step and
to enhance this process is to start taking mct oil
which will give you ketones directly you can also
take exogenous ketones in a tablet form they're a
little more expensive this is a lot less expensive
but the key is getting more ketones in the brain
that is going to immediately start turning things
around for you some other things that i would
recommend dha this is a healthy fat it's an
omega-3 fat it's in fatty fish it's in caldera
oil a good portion of your brain is made from this
zinc and vitamin b1 vital for supporting certain
parts of your brain that can regenerate like the
hippocampus so get your b1 from nutritional
yeast get your zinc from shellfish or a good
supplement or even beef or organ meats it's much
more bioavailable but vitamin b1 and zinc directly
support the hippocampus which is part of the brain
that is severely damaged when you have alzheimer's
the other thing you have to realize is that if you
have dementia there's probably some hypoxia going
on which means that you have a lack of oxygen or
part of the brain this is not getting the blood
flow it needs so exercise is vital to increase
oxygen as well as doing hyperbaric oxygen therapy
and there's even a therapy of restricting the
brain of oxygen while you exercise but you would
do that intermittently to increase oxygen which
will increase stress and cause your blood to carry
more oxygen so that's another therapy but let's
focus just on exercise right now and potentially
doing the hyperbaric the other thing that's
really important is getting enough sleep
if you have a sleep problem
like sleep apnea for example
that can create hypoxia and decrease the oxygen
to the brain or if you're getting a lack of
sleep that instantly increases your risk for
pre-diabetes insulin resistance and other health
issues and so one way to kind of reset your sleep
patterns is to start taking vitamin d and take it
probably minimally at 10,000 IUs every single
day and you're going to find that you're going
to start sleeping better that's just one thing
there's many things but that can definitely
help you as well as just taking vitamin d in
general which directly improves brain function
all right there you have it and if you want some
additional information i have a lot of videos
on the brain check them out i put them down
below before you go if you have a question
about a product or you're new to keto and you
want to know how to begin keto or you're on keto
and you need a debug because it's not going
as smooth i have a keto consultant standing by
to help you this is just for the people in
the US hopefully in the future we'll be able
to answer everyone's call but i put the number
down below so you can call and get some help